Hello, and welcome back to the complete guide
to spin at the Rawkode Academy.
Today, we're taking a look at the Node
JS SDK.
Much like the other SDK walkthroughs,
we're gonna cover
everything that you need to get started right
in your first WebAssembly
microservice
web Vermeion spin.
Let's dive right in.
Alright. Let's get started with the Node. Js
SDK.
The most common things you'll need to do
with the Spin SDK
is
your first endpoint.
When you run Spin New, it generates a
simple endpoint that just says, hello.
I'll guide you through the code that is
involved and the setup to get that running
locally.
Next, we'll grab some HTTP request headers,
then the body, then the query params,
and lastly,
we'll speak to another service.
When you start to build out your microservices,
you're inevitably gonna wanna speak to, well, one,
other microservices or two, other things on the
Internet.
So I'll show you how to get started
using Spin's SDK for outbound HTTP connections.
If you need any help, please feel free
to drop into the comment section. I'll keep
an eye on it, and I'll do my
best to help you get on your way.
So let's start looking at code.
So the first thing we want to do,
from PMPM and so on,
or whatever package manager you prefer to use.
Now that we have our dependencies,
we can pop open our index dot t
s.
You'll see here that the Spin SDK exposes
handle request, HTTP request, and HTTP response.
The handle request
is just a type definition that describes the
function that handles an HTTP request and spits
back an HTTP response.
HTTP request and HTTP response
are just object that allow us to grab
information about the request and our response.
Simple.
Now because we're using TypeScript today,
we have really great language server protocol
and our IDEs understand the code inside and
out.
You can click on HTTP response, and you'll
see the interface definition.
The only thing to know is that our
body is in a rebuffer.
If you're not familiar with the semantics of
WebAssembly,
essentially,
everything
is an array of integers or bytes.
I think that's right.
So we can't just throw text back down
the pipe.
Hence, we use the text encoder to encode
a string value into the array buffer.
Other than that, you're just writing standard TypeScript
code.
Let's run this and see what it looks
like.
We can run spin build
to compile our web assembly module.
We can then run spin up
with follow all,
Make our first request to our Node. Js
service.
And that's going to return a four zero
four, because as you can see at the
top of my screen, the endpoint that we
need is slash hello.
Now we have our hello from the Node
JS SDK,
and that's pretty sweet.
Alright. Let's take a look at headers.
First thing we wanna do
is grab our header or at least a
header that we're going to provide
called x name.
I'm just gonna pass my own name in
as a request header and we're gonna transform
it and propagate it back onto the response
and then include it in the body.
Super exciting.
Now we're gonna add some debug here.
Name is x n, like so.
Where the warning console dot debug is not
supported and spin
with the Spin SDK.
So you'll get function not found.
Now let's modify the response headers to include
x name
where we do x name and we'll transform
it
just to uppercase.
Nothing exciting,
but enough that we're doing something with it
we can see visually.
We could see on our response.
Lastly, we'll update the body
like so.
There is a few things to note here.
One, this is standard TypeScript code with the
exception of console dot debug. Nothing else here
is unique. We assign with constant assignment.
We're using string functions on strings,
and we have
template literals where we can interpolate variables.
All standard Node. Js, JavaScript, TypeScript stuff.
Your dev loop, it's around spin build and
spin up.
And I would encourage that you add follow
all so you can see the logs on
the console.
This will compile your program to a web
assembly module or binary
where we can run curl.
I'm adding dash v so that we can
see the response headers,
and I'm gonna add my own header on
the request.
And we'll set that to David.
Now we can request local host 3,000
slash hello, which is the endpoint that we
have configured and the spin dot toml.
We'll take a look at that in just
a second.
As you can see here,
our console printed name
is David.
We can see the response header of x
name is David in uppercase,
as well as the original x name of
David in the body response.
Now the other thing to note here
is that the HTP framework is part of
Spin's SDK,
always lowercases all of the headers.
Even though I passed it in as x
name like so,
this would actually give us an error and
a crash
because that key does not exist on the
object or the record.
So just keep that in mind. Always lower
case your header names.
So that's headers. Hopefully, nice and simple,
but nice to understand
how to fetch them and how to use
them.
Okay.
Let's understand the request body.
Let's do body equals
request
dot body.
If we hover over the variable, we get
our intelligent information from the IDE.
So this is either on a rebuffer or
undefined.
So let's do good error checking.
And if we don't have a body,
we'll return
a 400 and say this is a bad
request.
Now we do a console log for body,
not to print it out, but just to
understand where the TypeScript compiler thinks we are.
We can hover over and we'll see that
it's narrowed the scope of the type.
And now knows that beyond this point, we
always have an array buffer.
And in fact, let's actually run this and
see what we get on the terminal.
So we're gonna run,
spin build, spin up, follow-up.
There's a pattern here.
Next, we'll run the curl and we'll just
keep the same stuff that we had from
the previous request.
And you'll see here that we have an
object array buffer.
We're not actually getting a string. Again, web
assembly works with integers and bytes.
So let's get a string.
The easiest way to do this is to
say body string equals
buffer
dot from
passing on our body
and calling to string.
Now we can do a console log of
body string, and for good measure,
we can include it on the body response.
We come back,
we build,
and we wait.
And why does it look like nothing happened?
Well, nothing did.
We can see a blank line coming through.
What do we need to do? Include a
body.
Well, let's do dash d, and we'll pass
through an empty JSON object.
Now we can see that the body is
printed above in the logs and as well
as in a response
on the bottom.
Perfect.
So let's take a look at one more
thing before we move on to query strings.
I'm going to define an interface
called request
body.
And that's I'm going to have a string
name.
Down here, I'm going to say that my
request body is equal
to my request
dot JSON.
Now we haven't done any type matching here,
which means
we don't get auto complete
on our request body.
But the JSON function will parse the body
of this JSON.
Now
we can't just say that this is our
request body. What we actually need to do
here
is choose TypeScript's concept of as
a request body.
Now down here, we can see got the
name
request body
with auto complete
name.
So let's run spin build
and send a curl request.
This time passing through
the body with JSON.
And we got the name David.
So let's send a call request this time
with that
and we get undefined.
So it's always wise to remember
that while you're developing and writing and TypeScript,
that all that type information disappears
off to the at runtime.
So if you do need to make sure
your types are valid at runtime,
I recommend checking out Zod.
You can do a PMPM
install Zod.
From there,
you can define your Zod object.
You can see that our request body equals
Zod object,
which has a shape
of Zod string.
Now instead of defining our interface as a
duplication,
we can remove this
and we can say type
request body,
sort of fair,
type of request body.
So now we have two definitions of request
body in the same scope. One is a
value and one is a type, and that's
okay in TypeScript.
So we can choose to leave this as
it is,
but use our request body value to do
a parse on the object and see if
it's valid.
And you can see Copilot
already there with the answer.
So let's recompile
and send our field request
once the server is listening.
And now
we have a big large error telling us
that our types are invalid.
This may not be the best approach,
especially for production systems.
So you can change this
to safe parts.
Now this won't crash,
but you will have to evaluate the response.
You can then use response
dot success
to decide if you need to continue or
present the user with an error.
So this audio is really cool. If you
need runtime type safety and your Node. Js
microservices,
check it out.
Let's move on to query strings.
Now there's nothing special provided for you to
handle a query string. You will have to
parse it through regular Node JS code,
which means we're gonna have to pull in
the QS library.
You can do PMPM install QS.
From here, we can import star as QS
from
QS.
Like so.
Now that we have QS,
we can parse
the query string.
Let's do a const
query string equals q s dot parse.
Now the thing that's important to remember here,
that we have a request URI,
but the query string library
splits on the ampersand,
which means we still have the path in
there. So we have to manually
split the path off.
So we can just do split
based on question mark
and then grab the right hand side.
Next, we can just do console log and
say hello
limit
like so.
So let's set our limit to be equal
to query string
dot limit.
Well, that copilot pick a default 10.
Now we can use the syntax
because if we click on parse,
we see it returns a parse queues
and this is just a string indexable object.
So this should just work.
So let's build and run. We can do
spin build up and follow.
We can now do curl
local host 3,000
slash load,
and we see the default limit of 10.
In order to change this,
we have to quote our URL because of
the question mark
and set limit equals five.
And as you can see on the top,
we have the query string parsed and our
limit processed.
Alright. Last but not least, outbound HTTP.
You'll be pleased to know that you just
get to use the regular fetch API.
What does that mean? Well,
it means we get a const response
equals
await fetch tanker Copilot,
and let's actually just grab google.com.
That's it.
You'll see here, we have a response with
a fetch result.
So let's grab
the response body,
which equals await
response
dot text.
There's nothing new here. You don't need to
learn anything else. This is standard fetch API.
Let's do a console dot log response
body.
Next,
guess what we're gonna run? Spin,
build,
up, follow.
And we'll do a nice simple request,
local host 3,000
hello.
Now if you've seen the other walk throughs
for the other SDKs,
you'll see that we always had destination
not allowed.
Spin ships with secure default, which mean you
can only make outbound request to domains and
destinations that you specifically allow.
We can modify that in the spin.com.
Let's pop over to here.
Each component that you have
can define the allowed HTTP
host.
From here, we can set google.com.
Let's run our spin, build up,
and replicate our current request,
like so.
And as you can see on the server
logs at the top, we have the output
from google.com being console.log.
Now if you don't want to restrict outbound
access and you want to allow anything for
whatever reason, I promise, I don't judge.
You can change allowed HTTP hosts to be
insecure colon allowed dash all.
This will allow you to request any website
that you want.
That's it. We've covered the Node. Js, specifically
with TypeScript SDK for Spin.
I hope you found this useful. If so,
jump into the comments.
If you run into problems, jump into the
comments.
And if you want to see more videos
like this, click thumb up, subscribe, and go
check out Fermion Spin.
Happy hacking. I'll see you next time.